dans l'esprit des gens la soumission
chimique c'est le vert en boîte de nuit
dans lequel on met du ghb cette
soumission chimique touche absolument
tous les milieux socioprofessionnels
touche absolument tous les milieux
sociaux en général marie est une femme
comme moi comme vous son époux
le connais depuis 1970 ils ont plusieurs
enfants ils ont visité ils ont eu un
travail ils ont pris leur retraite
enfin ils ont une vie absolument normal
alors qu'elle revient de chez ces
enfants région parisienne marie est
informé par son époux de ce qu'il est
convoqué de au commissariat pour
récupérer notamment son téléphone
portable elle arrive dans ces conditions
commissariat de police et elle va
apprendre au cours de cette audition que
son épouse depuis très longtemps
là drogué et la livrer à d'autres hommes
pendant son sommeil dans le lit conjugal
sur les photos on peut constater qu'elle
est un con elle constate qu'elle est
inconsciente elle dit mais en fait je
suis une morte et donc ses hommes
abusent d'elle parfois son mari film
juste et parfois ils participent
au violent toutes ces bases sont
s'effondre toute sa vie tout tout tout
ce à quoi la crue s'effondre les
policiers qui ont fait un travail
extraordinaire je tiens vraiment à le
souligner ont pu se rendre compte que
depuis de très nombreuses années
monsieur échanger sur un site internet
avec d'autres hommes en réalité il est
il apparaît évident aux policiers dès
que dell visionnage de ces de ces vidéos
que la personne victime
cette femme est drogué finalement que ça
répond aussi à certaines questions à
certaines interrogations qu'elle avait
elle savait qu'elle avait des moments
d'absence ces enfants avaient attiré son
attention sur le fait que parfois les
avait au téléphone et elle tenait des
propos incohérents
il faut dire que il est certain que ce
qu'elle a appris ces du registre de
l'impensable donc elle elle n'avait
effectivement aucune raison aucune
possibilité de penser qui pouvait lui
arriver sain pour pouvoir l'imaginé
encore faut-il qu'on sache que ce existe
et c'est pour ça qu'il est vraiment
extrêmement important aujourd'hui de
parler de parler de cette soumission
chimique dans l'esprit des gens la
soumission chimique c'est le vert en
boîte de nuit dans lequel on met du ghb
le ghb elle est très loin d'être la
seule substance qui permettent la
soumission chimique d'une victime et il
faut savoir que il est aussi tout à fait
facile de donner des médicaments qui ont
des effets puissants hypnotique
puissants comme des médicaments basiques
comme les antihistaminiques comme des
anxiolytiques comme des bêtabloquants et
assurons des médicaments qu'on retrouve
dans nos pharmacies la soumission
chimique c'est le fait d'administrer à
quelqu'un à son insu une substance qui
va faire baisser sa vigilance qui va
faire en sorte qu' elle ne soit plus
elle même donc soit qu'elle s'endorme
soit qu'elle perde conscience soit que
ça la rend amnésique soit plusieurs de
ses éléments conjoint fait affaire met
en exergue beaucoup de vrais problèmes
de société
le premier problème de société c'est que
la pornographie la sexualité est
tellement galvaudé que eh bien ça ne
surprend presque personne qu'un homme
livre sa femme
à d'autres hommes qui eux acceptent
d'aller la violer
dans son propre lit le deuxième problème
que ça soulève c'est qu'effectivement
beaucoup disent mais son mari était
d'accord enfin bon moi je pense pas je
ne pensais pas que je la violer puisque
c'était son mari et qui me disait que je
pouvais y aller donc voilà donc il faut
quand même savoir que ça fait très
longtemps qu'une femme n'appartient plus
à son mari et que le consentement il
doit être recherchée avec la personne
avec laquelle on a une relation est là
ce consentement n'a jamais été
recherchées par personne ce qui
visiblement ne leur ne les a pas
empêchés de passer à l'acte sur cette
femme il est indispensable de lancer une
alerte d'envergure puisque cette
soumission chimique touche absolument
tous les milieux socioprofessionnels
touche absolument tous les milieux
sociaux en général et c'est trop facile
pour les auteurs et pas suffisamment
imaginables pour les victimes et pour
les personnels médical